o psol seja bem vindo só mais um vídeo e
hoje vou ensinar como fazer essa coisa
aqui que não sei bem o que é basicamente
um barco que tem rodas e para andar tem
uma hélice trás
aí está um vídeo patrocinado pela loja
good e à medida que for fazendo este
projeto e vou usar alguns elementos
eletrônicos que vocês têm que comprar se
não tiver em casa
a lista dos produtos que eu vou usar
aqui vai estar na descrição e agora
vamos começar
na base deste projecto vão utilizar
esferovite para criar uma espécie de
lancha
agora vocês podem usar outras coisas
quaisquer se o importante é criar uma
base que lhe permita colocar os
componentes todos porque vocês viram no
início do vídeo
eu vou utilizar uma bateria com o centro
de bloco 4 volpi e estrutura aqui que
vinha já com o controlador
este setor tem seis canais
isso aqui é um controlador de velocidade
e como vocês podem ver tem estas partes
que é preciso conectar os cabos
agora vocês podem comprar já com estudo
conectando só que vai ficar mais caro no
concelho que vocês compreendem essa
maneira e depois connect vocês próprios
ok
desta forma que é bastante simples
é o forró
ó
vou utilizar a estrutura aqui que é
bastante popular é por ser barato e
também ter uma boa qualidade que o
problema não tem nada de mal dizer em
termos de equipamento está perfeito e
tem muita velocidade
depois desse projeto quer usar o
instrutor para fazer um avião
telecomandado agora o problema é que eu
tenho uma teoria que é muito pesado
então eu não sei se eu tenho força
suficiente para levantar essa bateria
mas se não tiver então orange uma mais
pequenina
eu vou utilizar este serve aqui que é
feito de metal ou seja aquelas parte
interna é tudo feito de metal e e
consegue usar isto porque vão por um
touro em cima ou seja vai fazer alguma
atenção contra o cerro
isso foi plástico carlito que não vai
agüentar durante muito tempo então só eu
sei que o game que nesta parte dos
carros ficou caiu ao contrário ou seja
10 vocês têm conectar no canal e
hospital controlar sem conectar no canal
não só estamos à espera o filme agora só
que o cara está lá por cima para ficar
assim mais bonita
é eu sei que esse projeto não é nada
assim do outro mundo mas basicamente
como nunca tenha utilizado este tipo esp
controlo e instrutor aqui então eu
pensei fazer um projeto simples para
começar depois mais pra frente fazer
coisas mais complexas
então deixe nos comentários que vocês
gostariam que eu fizesse usando estes
servos e motores é e mails comentários e
tento fazer as coisas que eu acho mais
pequenos
nem nós ficamos o fim sol antes que
tenham gostado e se vocês comprarem isto
e sei que temos um pouco mais caro do
que comprar por exemplo só ouviam o
carro telecomandado mas o lado bom disso
é que vocês conseguem fazer muitos
projetos usando as mesmas coisas que
estou pronto e deveria ter sido até a
próxima do final